BUT FEELS LIKE ACTUAL JUSTICE,
HE'S ABOUT TO SUFFER GREATLY FO
A.
AT WHITAKER, AND THE FORMER
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL JAMES IS
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
EXPLAIN IF YOU WOULD WHY THAT
CHUMP CASE AND THE BIDEN CASE
ARE NOT AS DIFFERENT AS THEY AR
TELLING US ON MSNBC.
>> ON ONE HAND THEY AREN'T
DIFFERENT BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING
WITH CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN
WORD DEALING WITH THE STATUTE
THAT APPLIES TO THEM IN THEIR
HANDLING, BUT ON THE SAME TIME
OR DEALING WITH FORMER PRESIDEN
WHO HAD INTENDS TO DECLASSIFY
THOSE DOCUMENTS IN HIS
POSSESSION AND JOE BIDEN THE
VICE PRESIDENT HAD NO CHANCE TO
DECLASSIFY THOSE DOCUMENTS I
THINK IT'S INTERESTING FACT IN
THIS CASE, TUCKER, THAT THE
DOCUMENTS WERE IN MANILA FOLDER
MARKED PERSONAL SO YOU OPEN IT
UP IN ALL THESE MARKED
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ARE IN A
PERSONAL FOLDER.
THIS IS NOT GOOD FOR JOE BIDEN,
BUT I THINK ULTIMATELY, THIS IS
GOING TO GET DOWN TO WHERE
CAMILLE WAS AT WITH HILLARY
CLINTON.
IS HE GOING TO COME DOWN TO
APPLYING A STANDARD TO THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE THEM.
THERE IS NOTHING AND THE STATUT
ABOUT LOCKED GARAGES, AND
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT YOU DISCLOSED IT
AS SOON AS YOU FOUND IT.
JOE BIDEN, TO YOUR POINT HAD
THESE FOR OVER SIX YEARS.
>> WHETHER OR NOT YOU THINK THI
IS AN ORGANIZED EFFORT FROM
WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO
PREVENT BIDEN FROM RUNNING AGAIN
, I'M STILL CONFUSED AS TO
WHY WE DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS.
WHY HAVEN'T THEY TOLD US WHY
THEY WERE SEARCHING SIX YEARS
LATER FOR THESE DOCUMENTS.
YOU IS DOING IT?
GET THERE IS A LOT OF FACTS WE
DON'T KNOW.
IF YOUR MEMBER FAMOUSLY THEY
SPREAD OUT THE DOCUMENTS ON THE
DATE TOOK THE PICTURES SENT THA
TO THE MEDIA AND MADE SURE THAT
EVERYONE SAW THE EVIDENCE.
WE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
CONTENT OF THE DOCUMENTS, WE
DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT WHY WE
WERE TOLD BECAUSE HE WAS MOVING
OUT OF THE PATENT OFFICES AND
HIS LAWYERS WERE GOING TO THE
DOCUMENTS.
WHY GO THROUGH THE GARAGE?
THE OTHER THING THAT IS VERY
CONCERNING IS THAT HE WAITED FO
WEEKS TO APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL WHEN HE KNEW ON DECEMBE
MAJOR PROBLEM.
THEY WERE HOPING HE NEVER SAW
THE LIGHT OF DAY AND THAT IS AS
SAD FACT ABOUT THIS WHOLE CASE.
THEY DIDN'T WANT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO EVEN KNOW IT HAPPENED.
>> YEAH, AND THAT IS WHAT I
WOULD SAY